bernard henri lévy bonsoir voila tu
publies le numéro un d'une revue qui
s'appelle la règle du jeu je suis pas
seul dans cette histoire ouais vous êtes
un certain nombre d amener un via
scarpetta y en avait un comité à
l'action qui dirige cette revue avec moi
alors l'ambition de la règle du jeu
c'est de penser le post communisme parce
qu'au delà d'un autre ou la d'écoulement
d'un d'un régime c'est une civilisation
qui meurt d'une certaine façon et donc
non pas de combler le vide moment
l'explorer quoi c'est ça oui moi je
crois qu'on est en train de on est en
train de sortir du communisme et que des
sorties à des bonnes sorties et des
mauvaises sorties ya des vrais sortie il
ya des fausses sorties type de mauvaises
sorties par exemple ce serait un
déferlement de xénophobie de trivalis
voudra 6 mhz comme on voit dans la
sambre de pays de l'est
et comme on voit même en france bonne
sortie ce serait la démocratie le
libéral il d'une vraie culture que ce
volet dit moi je suis un écrivain qui
comme tony il ya un truc qui m'a
beaucoup plu il ya un regret dans ce que
tu écris en ce moment pour l'empiré
austro hongrois
sans être un mot je ne suis pas je suis
pas royaliste mais je crois néanmoins
que will empire austro hongrois avait le
mérite de d'établir une espèce de transe
en danse de la citoyenneté
qui qui permettait d'économiser tout un
tas de petites saloperies tribales
racistes et xénophobes avant 14
avant on était certes croates serbes
polonais ce slovaque était grave mais on
était en plus autre chose qui était
citoyenne l' empire austro-hongrois
sinon tu vas y fais tu ne regrettes
d'emploi vos tristes oui mais c'est pas
tellement qu'il regrette c'est que je
crois que tous les gens tous les gens
bien de ces pays là vaclav havel en
tchécoslovaquie georgie conrad en
hongrie tous les vrais démocrates des
pays de l'est regrette ce temps là oui
ils disent tous que enfin ils
s'orientent vers des solutions de
fédérations d'associations d'état qui
ressembleront d'une certaine manière à
ce qu est l empire austro-hongrois
je crois que c'est là c'est la nostalgie
majeur d'une bonne nouvelle alors en
quoi la règle du jeu avec plaisir ça me
fait énormément plaisir
en quoi la règle du jeu peut aider tous
ces pays de l'est à faire une bonne
sortie du communisme et doute la règle
du jeu
les intellectuels servent pas à
grand-chose la littérature lancement
ça n'est rien d'autre que la littérature
je crois néanmoins qu'il ya une bataille
d'idées en ce moment dans les pays de
l'est une bataille idéologique entre
entre deux il ya deux lignes ou si tu
préfères 2 europe qui sont en train de
se combattre dans une espèce de corps à
corps qui est je crois très dur l'un de
mes interlocuteurs en pologne qui est
adam michnik me parlait même d'une d'une
énorme affaire dreyfus à l'échelle de
l'ensemble de l'europe et qui dit
bataille d'idées dit rôle des idées je
crois que les producteurs d'idées les
gens qui font métier de penser
peuvent essayer de peser dans le bon
sens moi je
je pense par exemple que en pologne ou
en hongrie où il ya une vraie bataille
entre les entre les cosmopolites et les
autres on peut renforcer les
cosmopolites on peut leur apporter
d'abord notre amitié mais enfin une
belle jambe
accessoirement se tiendra désormais un
peu plus simple à organiser les choses
la règle du jeu ira
il ira on dit par exemple irradie
d'appel on fera des choses avec eux
alors sortir du communisme et puis
deuxième ambition de la règle du jeu le
droit de l'hommisme ça suffit plus
aujourd'hui face aux enjeux et par quoi
le remplacer alors ce droit de
l'hommisme qui était devenu quand même
le nec plus ultra de la pensée française
depuis une dizaine d'années ça suffit
plus ça veut dire ça veut dire en effet
que c'est un peu court je peux pas
répondre
il ya des problèmes énormes qui se pose
aujourd'hui en europe de l'est mais
aussi aussi en français et parce que on
donne beaucoup leçon aux européens de
l'aisne faudrait qu l'antenne vers une
revue tu diras pour la france croit
qu'il suffit pas d'ânonner droits de
l'homme droits de l'homme droits de
l'homme qu'il faut penser à bon si je le
serai pas une revue placé pour trouver
et vous trouvez pas si je fais une revue
c'est parce que je pense que ça prendra
du temps et il revit c'est quelque chose
qui s'installe dans la durée
j'espère que tu le sais c'est ce que tu
veux voilà alors tu as dit la fonction
des intellectuels c'est de produire du
complexe c'est pas de simplifier ses de
complexifier alors patron du
gouvernement contrairement à ce qu'on
croit donc voilà alors je vais poser des
questions simples et j'espère que tu vas
pas trop complexifier
si je te dis mao tsé toung qu'est ce que
tu me dis je dîne très très vieille
histoire
ouais un peu de un peu de ma jeunesse et
en même temps une histoire terminée ou
une autre elle est ma aux maoïstes ont
pensé quoi il ya deux choses y avait
pour les gens qui étaient des militants
mao qui militait au sein d'une
organisation qui appelle à gauche
prolétarienne devons ça j'en ai jamais
été bon les gens donnent eux comme julie
comme jambes et comme lardreau d'autres
étaient de l'été d'un gauche
prolétarienne c'était pas mon front de
gauche prg et moi j'ai jamais été là
dedans en revanche je crois oui un peu
quand j'avais 17 18 et 20 ans j'étais
dans cette mouvance là je pensais un peu
comme ça mais ça quand l'arrière par une
loi ça me parait de dix neuvième siècle
d'accord mais par l'ensemble c'est pas
ça consistait en quoi ça consistait à
croire qu'on pouvait changer l'homme en
ce qu'il avait de plus profond c'était
le slogan de l'époque ça consistait à
croire qu'on pouvait casser en deux
l'histoire du monde
c'est ce que disait mao en chine et
c'est ce que nous répétions oui si vous
pensez en effet qu'on pouvait enfin les
mao pensé qu'il pouvait en finir avec
avec l'histoire du malheur avec
l'histoire de là avec la mort avec la
mort non mac l'histoire du malheur en
tournée le fait d'être trompé à l'époque
depuis chaque fois que tu a émis des
idées tu t'es pas dit peut-être que je
suis encore en train de me tromper je me
le dis tout le temps mais moi je fais
partie des gens qui disent même lorsque
j'ai l'air matinal que péremptoire etc
je fais partie des gens qui se disent
oui bien sûr je pourrais me tromper
gorbatchev
ça c'est pas le visage avec ça ça c'est
maintenant ce qui m'agace avec
gorbatchev c'est cette espèce de
deux reflex midinettes compte un peu les
journalistes énormément les accidents
les gorges n'y a pas encore de chef
c'est autre chose c'est une entreprise
très tout à fait étrange assez atypique
unique me semble-t-il dans l'histoire de
soixante dix dernières années qui est de
sortir du communisme tout temps tout en
conservant deux parties il faut l'aider
et je crois je crois qu'il faut l'aider
oui je crois qu'il faut l'aider mais pas
à n'importe quel prix
je les pays baltes par exemple ils sont
pas d'accord il vient pas en avant pour
la paix il s'agit pas de donner on a
suffisamment donné de blanc seing
à d'autres on va pas en devient avoir
bâché bien sûr arafat arafat à rafah de
jeu
c'est quelqu'un qui sait quelqu'un pour
lequel j'ai pas une passion ne soyons
francs c'est quelqu'un qui est pas
seulement pour les raisons que tu
pourrais croire qu'on pourrait croire
c'est quelqu'un qui a soutenu à l'époque
l'intervention russe en afghanistan
c'est quelqu'un qui a soutenu j'arrose
est ce qui est la pire époque c'est
quelqu'un qui fait à peu près toujours
pris de mauvais parti dans les grandes
affaires du monde cela dit moi je suis
de ceux qui depuis des années et des
années je veux dire en israël même pense
qu'il faut négocier avec nous comprenons
pas encore négocié que ses ennemis et à
négocier
quand tu vois les drapeaux israéliens la
manifestation pour carpentras tu veux tu
penses quoi toi je pense que c'est très
con le pen le pen pour manger pour moi
c'est un voyou un tortionnaire et un
fasciste et puis c'est tout tu crois
qu'il faut le rendre inéligible
non je crois pas qu'il faut leur en
donner je pense qu'il faut le rendre
infréquentable jouer et ce qui est
différent de nous jean marie domenach a
passé pour vraiment comparer oui jean
marie doré que c'est une histoire assez
tristes parce que c'est quelqu'un qui a
pas été mal
qui n'a pas été mal dans la résistance
qui a même été bien enfin c'est un vrai
résistant et c'est quelqu'un qui est en
train de très belles tournées hockey
l'année dernière il ya eu un vrai
passage à l'acte antisémite cette
manière de se croire persécutés et
persécuté par les juifs ça devrait sa
part des intellectuels juifs
il a fait une espèce de petit délire
comme ça sur la place publique
expliquant que des gens comme visuel moi
je crois que j'étais dans le fourgon les
dividendes au sit in
c'est surtout triste parce que c'est
c'est en même temps c'est probablement
pas un intellectuel mais j'ai occupé
l'idéologie française
et puis que tu dis finalement le
pétainisme c'est giscard en haut que lui
chamba et puis quelques années après tu
dis le socialisme à la française c'est
le pétainisme dire ça veut dire que bon
la droite et pétainiste la gauche et
pétainiste
est-ce que tu suscites pas chez des gens
comme domenach humaine d'une certaine
façon parce que ils ont ils ont pas
envie d'être dans le sac là parce qu'ils
étaient résistants j'ai jamais dis les
choses tout à fait comme tu viens de
lire je dirais vue mais avec un peu de
rapidité
non j'ai dit en effet que il y avait il
y avait beaucoup de pétainisme en france
et qui en avaient souvent dans des
endroits qu'on ne soupçonnait pas en
effet qu'il ya du pétainisme à gauche
faurisson
faurisson moi j'ai pour règle de ne pas
prononcer son nom je viens d'enfreindre
la règle parce que je crois que c'est à
peu près aussi faurisson sait même pas
comment te dire c'est à peu près aussi
absurde c'est à peu près aussi
méprisables que un géographe qui dirait
la mer méditerranée n'existe pas les
métaphysiciens qui dirait la priory la
relativité je m'assieds mais si
quelqu'un qui arrive en des andes à
paulhan n'a jamais existé par exemple au
bout de deux minutes le débat est clos
donc pourquoi pas accepter le débat s'il
est qu au bout de deux minutes parce que
probablement les gens qui ont pour
métier d'organiser les débats de l'e de
l'efo nantais ont sur cette question là
où onze de perversité moi je crois que
la sphère faurisson a commencé à se
poser le jour où un journal a publié
face à face dans une grande et belle
page un article de faurisson et un
article d'un anti faurisson comme si les
deux thèses ce ballet et là je crois que
le mal était fait jean-edern hallier
jean et d'un ennemi je dirais que c'est
maurice axe sans talent sans judaïsme
vraiment pour nous sans la collaboration
et ce temps-là l'occupation à nourrice
qui lui restent basses maurice axe
bouksman où s'est perdue de vue
ouais je les ai perdus patrick besson
patrick besson écoute je connais pas
bien j'avais lu un livre j'ai lu un
livre de lui qui était le livre aussi
librement sur pouchkine que j'avais
trouvé que j'avais tout est bien bourdon
par exemple on lui sait pas rancunier
finalement vous avez ça dépend qui denis
tillinac
c'est là c'est la corrèze ou et dénis
oui moi je veux moi je préfère encore la
zambèze encore le zambèze à l'accord
entre amants talus morgan sportès
je sais pas qui fait si c'était je ne
sais pas si c'est parce que j'ai jamais
lu c'est déjà mes muscles ou celui-là
lui détient un mba
non mais tu sais pas quand les gens sont
terribles marc edouard nabe ont marqué
dans ma vie j'ai lu un de ses livres et
qui s'appelait au régal des vermines
et ça c'est un cap du visage moi je
pense que le personnage est à comment te
dire sans être
sans être accusés de territoire je crois
qu'il ya des choses qui sont infâmes
dans dans ce livre est insupportable
cela dit il n'est pas exclu que ce soit
en écrivant il n'est pas exclu que ce
soit à l'écrivain bernard henri lévy
d'avoir tu dirais quoi c'est était là en
face et qu'ils doivent parler but
je dirais que c'est un excédent des
corrections de ne rien rater de dinars
10 tubes abonnez vous mettez un pouce
bleus